I'm Pedro Pascal I'm Oscar Isaac and
we're doing a wired complete he told me
that I look like Duran Duran where's
Patrick Pascal from I am from Santiago
Chile okay how tall is Pedro Pascal I'm
511 these are the questions that people
are asking from Google scintillating
how old is Pedro Pascal ageless
the answer is ageless is Pedro Pascal is
nathan fillion really Pedro Pascal I
think Pedro Pascal was really Nathan
Fillion because that's Cal is Pedro
Pascal the mandalorian Pedro Pascal is
the mandalorian you're welcome I
convinced him to do it is Pedro Pascal
death why don't you answer that he's
certainly Oscar would say that I was I
die a lot I think that's why they asked
that's cuz I know you you're famously
die get killed off a lot yeah but you
just do it so well my head squished
thrown off Towers he's made a career by
dying's but if you watch Law & Order all
three of them I always die on Law &
Order you just got that kind of face
yeah you want to kill me just wanna kill
it Oscar Isaac cool who does Oscar Isaac
look like I get David Krumholtz often oh
I remember who you look like is it that
Muppet I told you about puppet the
grumpy angle the grumpy eagle hmm is
Oscar Isaac in spider-man the
spider-verse Miguel O'Hara
spider-man 2099 2099 my favorite movie
of the year I was texting him while I
was watching that movie do I have to
stay to the end of the credits where are
you i sat there and i saw the credits go
by and it said interesting person
interesting person number one Oscar
Isaac and I was like who the hell was
that I missed it
Oscar Isaac ooh oh I'm trying to read
these upside down was Oscar Isaac in
that 70 show no no no can Oscar Isaac
sing debatable debatable you're an
incredible singer and he finds the
opportunity to do it I inflicted on
people whenever I can whenever he can we
did a play together and somehow we there
was there were no songs in the play but
then there were mm-hmm
he's saying last night at Carnegie Hall
nope both of those things are wrong now
you're just a night before left okay but
it was thank you at Lincoln's major
Pascal peda Pascal dancing yeah I danced
is her video of you dancing I'm eating
it I don't know but I realized that I
didn't exercise but I would go out
dancing and that was my exercising and
if you drink vodka with grapefruit juice
it wasn't so bad because you were
getting a lot of vitamin C and he were
hydrating at the same time he's a
passionate dance but now with the age
question I'm gonna figure something else
out look-alike
I get Jeremy Renner I get Nathan Fillion
we're handsome people Quentin Tarantino
once baby chicken baby chicken when did
you know about that maybe chicken
somebody did my hair back and they went
to an Oscar party and there's a picture
of me in the baby chicken nailed it
Pedro Pascal pick your best girl
moustache you know what I'd like to talk
about the moustache I think today's the
day you see this this is powerful
clean-shaven five days ago this is this
is powerful facial this is this is
facial hair this looks like you're
undernourished I actually was doing a
play before narco started shooting and
the boss came to see the play and he was
like keep the stache and I was like okay
and now people are like don't ever get
rid of your mustache you look like my
grandmother without it Pedro Pascal SVO
vu
yeah I was on an episode of SVU let's go
to the next one hey what you doing it I
got killed I got shot your Pascal role
in Wonder Woman I play you did kill them
Google brothers put a chip in my head
and their brain explodes at you I feel
like we need to pick it up right kind of
like that where is Oscar Isaac from what
they must I was born in Guatemala I grew
up in Miami Florida is Oscar Isaac
related to Erik Estrada yeah no yeah but
my full name is Oscar Isaac getting on
this Estrada because my mom's name last
name is Oscar Estrada Jose Pedro
balmaseda Pascal is Oscar Isaac related
to George Clooney yes inside I am you
know it's the is Oscar Isaac left-handed
nope only sometimes right is Oscar eyes
when I will kick to feel like someone
else nice he's not nice he's not very
nice
he portrays himself to be very nice and
he's literally the only person who has
given me a wet willy since I was 14
years old that's disgusting
and it smells like a butt pascale Star
Wars it's all true
yeah Pedro Pascal narcos also true so
I'll just sing too
I'll just sing - soy el fuego - can we
sing all the things yeah okay Pedro
Pascal and Buffy
[Music]
April second nineteen nineteen
twenty-two Federer Pascal dr. fate
what's that
I think that's a character from the DC
Comics and people are curious if I'm
playing dr. fate and I'm here to tell
you that know what Oscar Isaac what what
- what what is Oscar Isaac I've done
this Estrada Latino Guatemala take all
the magic of our nation Cuba nation the
Cuban nation yeah what language does
Oscar Isaac speak what would you call it
the language of love the language of
love I would call it the language of
love what Oscar Isaac guitars is Oscar
Isaac play well I just bought one today
the Martin 21 D 21 but I
I generally play the Elwha Gibson l1
from 1927 it's the one that I had played
in Lou and Davis at the end of that
movie that gave me that guitar so that's
the one that I play but if I had to
answer that I would have said the
classical guitar would that make any
sense
nope when we did a play together his
character suddenly knew how to play
guitar classical use what you got use
what you got like this
thanks for googling me Internet thanks
for googling him Internet